Now let's go back and
analyze that same problem
that we were looking
at before of a wheel
rolling down an incline plane.
And it's rolling
without slipping.
But instead of using
the energy method,
we're now going to
use the torque method.
So let's consider
the center of mass.
And what we want to
do is draw the forces.
We have a normal force.
We have gravity.
And we have the friction force
about the center of mass.
Our wheel has a radius R.
Let's choose a coordinate
system i hat, j hat.
And so we have a
right-handed system k hat,
and that will correspond
to some angle theta.
Now here we're now going
to enlarge how we apply
both translation and rotation.
And the beauty of
this problem is
we now can decompose our motion
into translational motion
and rotational motion.
So for the transitional
motion, we'll
apply Newton's second law.
Now, if this is the
angle phi, then that's
the angle phi as well.
And so our forces in
the i hat direction, we
have mg sine phi minus
the friction force.
And that's equal to the x
component of the acceleration.
Now we also can choose
the center of mass
to calculate the torque.
And so what we're really
just studying here
is simply our old problem in the
center of mass frame of fixed
axis rotation.
And you can see gravity is
acting at the center of mass.
So it produces no torque
about the center of mass.
The normal force is directed
towards the center of mass.
And so when we take that vector
product of R cross n from cm
to this point down
here, the contact point,
these forces are anti-parallel.
So the normal force
produces no torque.
And the only torque that we
have is from the friction force,
and that friction
torque is going
to give us a positive angular
acceleration in the k hat
direction.
It's at right angles
with the vector R.
So we have fs times R equals
I center of mass times alpha.
And these are our two
dynamic equations.
But remember, when the object
is rolling without slipping,
let's just remind ourselves
that Vcm equals R omega.
And if I differentiate, the Acm
which is what we're calling ax,
is equal to R alpha.
So this ax here is
the acceleration
of the center of mass.
And that's our third condition.
And so now I see that
I have three equations
and my unknowns--
fs, ax and alpha.
And so I'm going to solve
these equations for a.
And I'll look at
these equations.
And what I'll do is I'll just
substitute for alpha ax over R.
And then solve this equation
for fs, and put it in there.
And so I get mg sine phi.
Now my fs is equal to
Icm over R times alpha.
But alpha is ax over R. So
that's ax and an R squared.
Notice dimensionally,
I is mr squared.
So this is just
ma, the dimensions
of force, mg dimensions of
force, and that's equal to max.
And now I can solve for ax.
And I get mg sine phi divided
by m plus Icm over R squared.
Now ax is a constant.
And we can, from our
kinematic equations,
if our object is
moving a distance s
as it drops height h,
we know from kinematics
and we can work this out.
We have that Xcm is
one half Acm t squared.
And we know that the velocity
Vcm equals Acm times t.
And so when we put
these two together,
this is the distance s,
we get that the velocity
cm is equal to the square
root of 2s times Acm.
Now s is equal to
h over sine phi.
S h over s is sine phi.
And so the Vcm equals the square
root of 2h sine phi times Acm--
but we've solved for Acm--
mg sine phi over m plus
Icm over R squared.
And so we get the
square root of 2mgh
over m plus Icm
divided by R squared.
And this agrees with
our energy method.